hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play a Louis's
okay this was really hard to find even
when someone told me exactly where to
find it I still couldn't but you hear
that
it's a dripping clue and just like the
cam before there's an audio clue to
things that I need to find so this might
be helpful okay so I need to keep an ear
out and the volume up which is probably
a bad thing oh and the monsters started
coming but I need to keep things up so
that I can actually look out for stuff
okay why I don't know why that didn't
save with that already open but whatever
so I got my inventory No
oh I didn't save with that you got to be
kidding me why did it save back there
that doesn't make any sense what did I
even find the girl yeah what you what I
didn't even find the generator Damon I
gotta go find the axe again
I got triggers a trap I didn't know this
Rell so I would have done this before
and I don't know why cuz there is no
option to like save or anything so I
didn't know I'm I don't know I don't
know I'm so sorry I did know okay so it
won't be that much longer I just got it
jot down here find the can which I
should be able to you don't doing okay
cool and then there's a pile of dirt I
don't know if that had a sound to it if
there was sewn to it that's probably a
bad thing but I'll go back to the pile
of dirt later if I have a shovel I'm
sure I'll need to go back there at some
point but I just got really lucky and
finding that not really lucky in finding
the hose okay so you're already over we
go okay so if we put the hose in to the
best spa there we go need something to
pour the gas in Kurt soon I've got suck
it out with a straw and then put it in
cuz the way fluid dynamics work can I
get that back do I need that I might
need that for now okay apparently I do
not all right and can I chop the best
bar in half with an ox that's what I'd
like to do I've got the volume turned up
now so I kind of hear things I thought I
heard some some growly
dudes dark inner need to get the light
on maybe I can use his old generator
well good thing I could haha good thing
i wrote full on the side of that in
their car chung dang and now all the
monsters in the world get attracted to
me oh this this doesn't look nearly as
bad as i thought it was gonna be I
thought this whole place was gonna be
like covered looks like everyone drank
the wine was that like the kool-aid of
this time okay anyway anyone everyone
drank the wine so I don't see where the
truth would be it works fine now yeah
okay that's fantastic but I need like a
key or something shouldn't there be a
key in here well what am I supposed to
do now how the lights are on and these
are empty well what are we gonna do
about that I just took that in the wall
take that physics
nope nothing nothing nothing like hidden
in these glass bottles well what was the
point of this maybe the generator turned
on everything else in the town I don't
know lady lady what the heck is going on
lady lady I turned on the thing there's
no wine I know you really want to drink
right now but there is no wine available
anywhere lady lady need to find a key oh
it's got to be in there it's got to be
in there I just overlooked it so let me
go in there and be very quiet so that I
can hear all the generators too loud but
I'll hear a key that's what I'll hear
all right very carefully
up here no over here no on the hooks no
on the top shelf no oh
this barrel steams empty I got it smash
yeah what huh what's going on hi
let's go in there buddy nice robe oh
don't kill the lady
what so you heard him coming but he
didn't hear the generator and you
clanking and smashing things alright
then I think he left now I'll just hold
this axe you know ya know me no trust ah
ha ah ah ha I know I know I knew you
Trixie he's Trixie well this isn't good
what am I being carried over his
shoulder oh that's so nice of him he's
gonna bury me in by that dirt pile
probably well I'm glad he's unlocking
everything so that's awfully nice Oh
chatter - yes making progress doing good
alrighty Tara things are getting
interesting now I can tell this is gonna
be a really good game I really like
everything that's been going on so far
like very steady buildup very
interesting stuff where am I
oh they're burying me alive no you can't
I need to get out of here and fast use
my axe maybe I can move my arm and put
the lid I really wish that I could do
something here but apparently I cannot
yeah I run you little baby I need to get
to the woman before they do ok yeah why
would he just run away is he really that
big of a boy I got a lantern now ah
Elda toggle the lantern okay well this
will be much more helpful but I guess
I'm gonna need fuel for it anyway I need
to get to the lady I don't even know
where I am
I mean well obviously I'm in a cemetery
everyone thank you so much for that but
I just need to find my bearings in a
relationship to the town of some sort
gosh I hope they don't hurt her do I
still have the key I do not or maybe I
do which way do I go I don't know I'll
go this way
oh you're kidding me oh no wait I
thought this was
a road that I went into the house okay
it's apparently completely different
road okay all right gotta find the woman
she's a black magic woman
Bernier got a basketball hoop what what
setting was this it was 1998 right lots
of empty houses or maybe they're not
empty and everyone's just not answering
maybe I'm the psychopathic murderer okay
here we go
maybe I'm the psychotic guy they're all
like hiding oh when will he go away
please just take care of him uncle Jerry
just bury him at the cemetery make him
go away and Jerry's like oh I nailed
that down good and I'm just like super
powerful I'm like boom boom and he was
like no oh come on
too late must have taken her how do I
even know who she is
clues at houses around the villages oh
great
I gotta go in every single house again
uh-oh wait there was another unlocked
pass up here let me go this way probably
the correct way to go yeah I have a
sneaking suspicion that I am a
psychopathic murderer
and I was like brutishly strong and
that's why he was so scared of me go
away you monster look Bob I'm going to
throw this into the basketball hoop from
here first wonk aha so close I'll get
that later
okay oh hello it's all oh wait wait wait
wait wait wait you're us I knew whose
weird that there was a rug here oh come
on oh here we go Kurt Jahnke oh yeah
haha on the radio
gasp can guess can
hello nothing chest no open up all bad
you obey me chest all right nothing else
anything under their new are sick
upstairs do I get hidden heading again
by a guy hope no one Minds me barging
into their house like this perfectly
normal nothing in there anything in here
it is my demand I Oh Baba note here's
the key to the general store don't
forget to bring two bottles of wine and
some barrels some barrels of wood some
barrels of what man ok now go out on the
balcony anything out on the balcony Oh
time to make that amazing three-point
shot I bet there probably was like an
achievement or something free to be able
to nail the basketball hoop from this
porch or like this ledge here ok nothing
but silverware in there anything in
these nope I'll smash your [ __ ] though
take that nothing breaks alright that
was a disappointment
now I gotta find the general store I am
strong I can throw those rocks like
wicked fast man alright so where's the
general store was it in the it was in
the center of town it was the one that
had all the signs over it I believe so
and I'm gonna make this oh there was one
down here to her trunk
I throw too hard there isn't really a
light option to throw yeah alright screw
that I'm not gonna waste time trying to
get that in there I don't care how many
achievements are available to me all
right where was the other way to go this
was not the other way to go where was
the other way to go where would the
other way to go I know there was another
way though I could get to the way a way
that I was going now here it is okay so
we go into here we're going into the
general store and we should be able to
have something car not both nice you're
a coffee house okay that's the coffee
house general store here we go alright
it's got a heart-shaped key how lovely
kliklak
is wrong hello jingled uncle BAM well
now mr. general store man all right is
there anything here
aha that looks like a little some of its
horseshoe key and scale broke so taken
to the blacksmith he is out of town but
he left me the key to store oh okay well
I'll take it for you I'm so nice you
guys are gonna love me after this right
right I can't get through that what can
i what can i oh I should get the
batteries before I leave
oh thanks for that I didn't even know
this place had batteries cool I can put
away the Lateran oh I like that lantern
better what are you doing
huh what are you talking about the
lanterns like way better look at the
difference it's like look at that it's
like night and day
Jesus what are they thinking they're a
bunch of crazies okay so now I got to
find the blacksmith wherever he is if
this was the coffee house and though it
was a general store where would the
blacksmith be maybe he was up at the top
of town
because there were a couple things up
there at least as far as I saw that was
the house on the wood the blacksmith be
there no idea your map I don't have a
map and I'm just gonna have to do it by
trial and error I don't like these woods
I don't like them I like anything out
here but okay this is where I came in
from the cemetery so I'm gonna assume
that it's not up that way just kind of
stomping around these woods at night in
the dark just a little disconcerting
okay so where oh where would the
blacksmith be I do not know but he's
gotta be one of these buildings here
that's the church here's the steeple
open the door there's all the people
okay I'll just try it on most of the
doors maybe I'll get you get lucky maybe
I'll get lucky oh we must have been down
here there was another building with a
sign over it wasn't there maybe maybe
maybe maybe baby no no no I'm wrong I'm
wrong my story on my life I'm just wrong
to plain old wrong
I can't win maybe this was the
blacksmith who knows maybe nope this
will not do
where's the blacksmith where's the Mark
Smith what what oh okay no I'm lost a
Ken man this game is really good at not
giving you clear directions haha
I wish I knew what I was doing I really
do
boy I wish I had a sense of direction
and clear orders well maybe in my
journal it said like exactly where
nope just blacksmith's workshop oh oh
maybe one of these this won't do this
won't do
can't use this here this won't do won't
do won't do okay it's locked okay so
it's no building round here I haven't
tried the church but I'm pretty sure
that's not a blacksmith if I'm wrong on
that one I'm gonna be so pissed okay all
right let's just carry on try to find
something like ah over here course of
course of course
nope never mind that's a lie it's all a
lie it's all a big scam where the hell
is the blacksmith why does it get darker
when I go out and into the woods
I'm just the key maniac I'm just
stomping through the woods with a key in
front of me Oh where's the blacksmith
all the villagers are huddled up in
their homes like why does he want to do
with the black Smithers we don't have a
voicemail
where's the black man apparently there's
a war being fought outside this is not
correct what is this this is an
amphitheater what is this this is not a
box where's the blacksmith Oh God okey I
need
blacksmith I did try every building in
town
Tommy I mean what else can I do
where's the blacksmith where's the
blacksmith come back here Tommy was a
black bastard come on Warren Warren I
will find the blacksmith that's making
me lightheaded uh-huh this Justin
markiplier dies from playing video games
huh found dead alone in his apartment
with watching some woman move her butt
cheeks to the beat of Beethoven it was
really a sad sight oh man what am i
doing what am i doing what am i done
what uh-oh
don't jump down there I'm like
completely lost now oh come on can I use
the key on this can I please whoa why is
he using the key on the ladder
we don't know where's the blacksmith
ladders not a book where's the
blacksmith wah all right I'm I'm done
you guys tell me what to do cuz
obviously I'm too stupid to figure it
out I was doing great for a bit there I
got stuck can't find the blacksmith I
guess leaving town was probably not the
best choice but I was hoping that there
would be another building on the
outskirts but anyway
where's a blacksmith make him go away
make him go away my name is markiplier
thank you for watching who's he talking
to
and as always hosszú in the next video
bah-bah
Oh
but
all right